in the last video we saw napoleon's army
get decimated especially as they tried
to retreat from russia the numbers i
threw out in that videos he started off
with on the order of 450
000 soldiers under his command and then
when he retreated it was on the order of
ten thousand soldiers i just wanna take
a little aside here these numbers aren't
firm historians aren't even sure on the
exact numbers and sometimes you'll see
accounts of
five hundred to six hundred thousand
entering and thirty to forty thousand
leaving i went with these numbers just
because on bernard's map these were
pretty close to those numbers right here
is four hundred twenty two thousand
leaving he has ten thousand right there
but i just wanna make sure you realize
that these aren't exact numbers and
depending on i guess how you account for
his troops whether you're talking about
troops directly under napoleon's command
whether they are troops that are
directly involved in the offensive
invasion of russia or they're just
troops that are maybe supporting it
you're going to get different numbers
and depending on whether you view you
know troops and how you count the
casualties so it's all about how you
account but needless to say his the the
the french grand army was decimated
after invading russia and i even told
you at the end of the last video that
after that the rest of europe the the
these the other countries that kept
forming and reforming coalitions against
napoleon began to smell blood so you
already have you could already view the
invasion of russia as the beginning of
the sixth coalition you already had
great britain
great britain throughout this entire
time period throughout the napoleonic
wars was and even during the french
revolution was in a constant state of
war with the french and napoleon
obviously you have russia now
russia now is also going to is also
a a belligerent is also an antagonist
against napoleon they you know just
because he retreated doesn't mean the
war with russia is over
prussia had been humiliated multiple
times by napoleon and now they jump
they jump on the bandwagon after seeing
after hearing about napoleon getting
decimated
and so they a combined russian and
prussian forces engaged napoleon
but as as much as napoleon's forces seem
to have gotten decimated so if you look
at that menard map up here that we went
over in some detail in the last video
that covers right here the invasion of
russia started right about here and it
went right about in that direction right
there so napoleon he's now retreating
back and he might say gee he only has
ten thousand or 20 000 or 30 000 troops
that's nothing he's just going to be you
know put out
very quickly by the combined allied
forces but napoleon as you know we we
kind of say regardless of what you think
of him as a person he was no dummy and
he was good at raising forces and he was
a very very very good military tactician
he was very quickly able to raise to
take his 30 000 soldier army get it to
130 000 and eventually he's able to get
it to 400 000. although this force right
here it's not going to be the same
quality of 400 000 as the 400 000 that
he might have had say entering the
russian campaign and there are other
troops also that were allied with
napoleon german troops from the
confederacy of the tr of the rhine that
were sympathetic to the french empire
but once again they weren't as
disciplined or under as direct control
of napoleon but it's neat you know
needless to say he was able to very
quickly very quickly get up to some
reasonable force that could maybe maybe
withstand a sixth coalition but the
sixth coalition was much larger it's on
the order of so depending on the account
you look at
the sixth coalition
they amassed forces mainly in what's now
germany but at that time the
confederation of the rhine and before
that the holy roman empire of on the
order of 1 million troops not one
million dollars one million
one million soldiers so even though
napoleon was able to raise a force he
was still outnumbered in the in what's
now germany or in the germanic kingdoms
he was still outnumbered by a factor of
two to one but despite that the first
several engagements with the combined
russian and prussian army napoleon was
victorious or i shouldn't say the
victorious because that implies too much
he he won those battles and these are at
lautzen
lautsen at boutsin
and then at dresden he had a very
significant victory
dresden and these are all right about
here just so you have a sense of the
geography you can actually see
dresden on the map there and after these
defeats the the the coalition said gee
you know this napoleon character even
though we outnumber him even though he
he had to kind of very quickly get these
troops he's a really good military
tactician and he's still kind of kicking
our butt on the battlefield they then
issued what's called the let me write
this down the trackenberg plan
trackenberg plan although it's not clear
that they really had to
the trackenberg plan which essentially
says try not to engage forces that
napoleon is
in command of directly
try to engage his people that napoleon
has had to delegate to his marshals the
other generals so
don't
engage
napoleon one day i'd like to make more
detailed videos on the actual kind of
you have to say the actual genius of
napoleon on the battlefield and go
battle by battle and see why people
consider napoleon to be a great military
commander but his enemies definitely
appreciated the fact that despite being
outnumbered he was very tricky and very
wily and was always able to kind of
snatch a victory from defeat so they had
this plan to say hey let's just not
engage napoleon we have so many troops
let's just try to
incur losses on the french
on other commanders other than napoleon
but needless to say they hugely they
hugely outnumbered hugely outnumbered
the french all of the fighting was going
on
all of the fighting was going on in this
general area at the time and at leipzig
and just so you get a sense of time
remember the the invasion of russia was
at the end of 18 so let me write this
down so
the russian invasion
so russia
let me just in another color
right here so the russian
invasion
that was at the end
end of 1812 it was really kind of the
beginning of winter in 1812 that really
decimated napoleon's troops then in
then we go to 1813
you're looking at lautzen and boutsin
lautsen
and
boutsin
that's in may
may of 1813. so after the that winter
that gave napoleon some time to get his
troops together and things happened
slower this day and age people didn't
have perfect intelligence in terms of
what was going on in the battlefield and
it actually took time for just
information to travel and for armies to
travel they were traveling mainly on
foot at that time and then august 1813
august
august you had napoleon's significant
victory at dresden
at dresden but then finally 1813
1813 in october
and at this point
the coalition had convinced austria to
also join in so this is kind of the
ultimate coalition if you look at most
of the coalition they seldom had both
austria and prussia and russia and all
of these guys but now they're all piling
on so now you have austria
austria's part of the coalition and
sweden
and of course you can't forget what's
happening in the iberian peninsula you
have all of the rebels in spain
and portugal so you pretty much have
every major power in europe is now
allied against napoleon and in october
of 1813 especially the austrians
prussians and russians they meet him at
leipzig
they meet him
at leipzig which is right
over here and at leipzig they outnumber
him two to one and they were able to
take care of him and force him to
retreat
so then leipzig happens first really
major defeat this is an actual image of
the battle of leipzig they call it the
battle of the nations
battle
of
nations because so many people were so
many uh uh belligerents were involved in
this battle people estimate that there
were six hundred thousand
six hundred thousand soldiers involved
four hundred thousand on the side of the
sixth coalition two hundred 000 on the
side of napoleon and they estimate on
the order of a hundred thousand
dead
dead or wounded so this was a major
major super bloody battle and it forced
napoleon to
retreat so he had to retreat from russia
before and now he's retreating from the
confederation of the orion which was
essentially french controlled territory
so napoleon is really on his heels he
now is going to defend france and now
remember at the same time of this you
had you had all the stuff going on in
the peninsula you had arthur wellesley
you remember him right here that's
arthur
wellesley
he's the british general leading you
could view them as the rebels in spain
and portugal at the end of 1813 he's
winning a series of victories against
the french and he's pushing
into
france this is the pyrenees mountains
right here he's crossing he's he's
winning a series of battles in the
pyrenees and then in the last-ditch
effort and napoleon once again he's
hugely outnumbers he starts he engages
his enemies in battles in northeast
france right around that area and
there's actually a period there's the
six day campaign
and this now we are in 1814 so that was
leipzig was at the end of 1813 he
retreats now we're in 1814
and the beginning of 1814 in february
you have the six day campaign
six
day
campaign and this was kind of napoleon's
final shot at really showing his
military genius despite the fact that he
was hugely outnumbered there were four
significant battles where he was
essentially able to at least in those
battles route the coalition despite
being hugely outnumbered so he kept
showing his military genius but at some
point the numbers just became
overwhelming and the french troops just
couldn't handle the coalition especially
being decimated after being dismayed in
russia and then losing significant
troops uh even in some of their
victories in what what is now germany or
the confederation of the rhine then
and then the allies the coalition
eventually in march
in march of 1814
march the sixth coalition we could say
the coalition
marches into paris
they march
into paris and this right here is an
image of the russians marching into
paris
russians
march
into
paris around the time around march of
1814 but napoleon didn't want to give up
in april
in april napoleon's telling his generals
let's go let's go retake paris but
finally the generals are ready to give
up on napoleon and they refuse to follow
him and napoleon says hey you know then
i'm going to tell the troops to follow
me and then there's like well you could
try but they're not going to follow you
so they essentially don't agree to do
anything that napoleon wants forcing
napoleon and you know it was going to
happen one way or the other this way is
just less bloody in april of 1814 super
important time in history napoleon is
forced to abdicate
napoleon
is abdicates
and not only does he abdicate he's you
know i won't maybe i'll do a future
video on it but he also has to rescind
any claim that any of his his um his his
uh of you know his son or any of his
future uh uh
uh what's the not the word ancestors
what's the opposite of ancestors
descendants any of his future
descendants might have cl claim as
emperor france or or king of france so
he's forced to abdicate future super
important time 1814 so if you think
about when napoleon ruled remember he
had the whole he he was able to take
power at the end of
1799 so it's been on the order of 13 or
14 years where napoleon has just
been the absolute ruler of france and
has been able to really kind of wreak a
lot of havoc on europe and now it all
comes to an end and we'll see it's kind
of temporary now but it's
we're getting near the end of hearing
about napoleon they force him to
abdicate by the treaty of fontainebleau
treaty
of
fontainebleau
fontaine
blue and they exile him to elba so this
is just you know where elba is a little
island off the italian coast right here
this is elba
this is where napoleon was forced to
stay doesn't seem like that
bad of a place and they actually let him
keep the title of emperor and they
allowed him to rule over elba and he was
actually able to do some reasonably
constructive things with the island
you're going to see he leaves the island
very shortly but it wasn't that bad i
mean you know in modern days if someone
was indirectly responsible or directly
responsible for butchering millions of
your civilians or soldiers you wouldn't
send them to a nice you know a place
with a nice climate and give them a nice
house like this and allow them to
actually rule over the island but i
think at this time all of these generals
and kings they all viewed them as you
know they all they all had they all
viewed each other as gentlemen and they
never wanted to be too
too vicious to each other just in case
the
things were to come back around to them
i guess but he got exiled to elba in as
i just said what was it april of 1814
and then the coalition we'll talk more
about this
they put louis the 16th you remember
louis xvi with the whole french
revolution and the estates general they
put his younger brother they restore him
to the crown there this is right here is
louis
this is louis the 18th
x-v-i-i-i
this is louis the 16th younger brother
the younger
brother
they make him king of france so i had
all that business about the french
revolution then napoleon comes to power
and all of these the rights of man and
all that when everything's said and done
they put a king back in power this guy
with his satin robes again doesn't look
too different than his older brother and
just in case you're wondering you know
his older brother is louis xvi he is
louis the 18th who was louis the 17th
this is louis the 17th
right here that is
louis
the 17th
louis xv this is louis the 16th son he
was actually next in line to the throne
before his uncle or louis the 16th
younger brother louis the 18th but he
died he was kind of you know while he
was in prison if you are a royalist you
would have considered him king after the
after the beheading the decapitation of
his dad and actually there's a hugely
fascinating story here where people they
say that he died in 1795 but
many many people think that he escaped
and
was labeled to live a normal life and
you know who knows what but needless to
say he wasn't anywhere to be found so
they made louis the 18th louis the 16th
younger brother king of france but we're
going to see this isn't the last we hear
of napoleon